Don't stop singing.
And that's because at a certain point
when I became 16 or 17,
I stopped singing
and really being used to hearing my voice.
And for many years,
I wasn't comfortable in front of people,
speaking,
sharing my opinions,
just making my thoughts known
and available for other people.
And I think that it took me a long time
to find my voice again.
And I think if I hadn't stopped singing
and being in front of people like that,
I would have probably been able
to share a lot more of what I thought
in those important years.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.